all right so good number of people in
our office tried to get into middle gear
survive and play their Salvage missions
and found it pretty confusing the game
has a pretty complicated crafting system
upfront and the staging area can be a
bit convoluted so we're gonna take you
through some tips to get you through
your first couple of rounds and some
pretty cool ways to set up traps and
defend your base so before you start the
first thing you should know is that you
can't invert your controls from the
staging area only the main menu that one
took me way too long to figure out so if
you play inverted do it after the
customization section but before you
start the game once you get to the
starting area you'll find yourself in a
sterile environment it's really not too
bad there's two main stations you need
to go to first head over to the supply
box where the game will give you rewards
blueprints and materials pretty much go
the supply box after every round or when
you log in and check it for material you
can then take that over to the
customization area where you pretty much
craft everything there's a menu where
you can actually go and give yourself a
couple more item slots and I recommend
doing it in general having a mixed
loadouts pretty important you aren't
good crowd control such as shotguns
range weapons such as assault rifles hit
the legs of exploding enemies and a
trusted melee weapon now the game
doesn't actually start you off with a
lot of material so what I recommend is
actually going into a couple of solo
Salvage missions and completely ignoring
the wormhole generator what I found is
if you walk around and just collect
material even if you fail you get to
take it with you back to your starting
area so consider failing a couple times
building up your resources and using
that to go to the crafting stations and
crafting your first set of good gear
fences and traps all right so you're
ready to do your first salvage mission
you have to go to the accept mission
area and neither accept quick match
which will start on the matchmaking
lobby or pull your friends in but either
way you have to both select the mission
and then walk over to another deployment
circle to start the mission craft as
much ammo and as many barricades as you
can before matchmaking because you only
have about five minutes once you get
into the round to get to the area that
you have to defend and also you won't
pick up much on the way there that's
gonna help you build anything you may
find yourself getting wounded by the
first set of zombies on your way there
there's a couple different types of
damage there's general damage which you
can use a spray to get rid of and
they're specific damage which you need
to go into the menu to heal you'll know
if you have a specific damage on your
body because you'll see continuous
bleeding on screen on the easier salvage
missions you can probably ignore
specific damage because the round will
be over before
becomes a problem the other thing you're
on the lookout for our coupon crystals
they look like little plants and you can
use those points to level up characters
or throw them to attract zombies now
once you get to the defense area the
biggest noob mistake we're seeing right
now is people placing their traps and
barricades inside of the red circle but
what you have to do is build outside of
that red circle because the warp gate
will actually destroy your gear
barricades between waves in your
inventory you'll also find a warp point
this is not for kidnapping creatures
it's actually something you can put
anywhere on the map and teleport to so
put it somewhere safe like up high and
then if you get in trouble you can warp
yourself to safety now you'll see the
zombie pass right away it varies
depending on the map but the zombies
really do stick to these arrows you can
go ahead and start deploying fences
along those lines and as long as you
stay behind the fences the zombies will
pile up on them
the zombies won't actually go around the
fences unless there's a player standing
right next to one and a zombie lunges
sideways hi bear kids or low barricades
are both equally as good they slow down
zombies and let you attack through them
if you look through the menu each one
will say what kind of melee attacks are
compatible at this point you can start
experimenting with fun trap combos we
like putting a propeller in front or
behind a fence if it's in front of the
fence then the zombies will get ground
up as they go into the fence if it's
behind the fence the zombies all topple
over at the same time and get ground up
after they fall
another neat combo is to toss crystals
at a horde of zombies which they'll all
bunch up around and then follow up with
a grenade now after a couple of rounds
you can actually go find a walker so if
you see people running around with those
they found them on the map and they're
pretty much a guaranteed win at the
easier levels all right so let's say you
made it to the end of the round there's
some things you should do to conserve
your resources such as if the countdown
timer says 10 seconds left and the
zombies aren't anywhere close to the
warp gate conserve your ammo because you
have to craft everything in this game
you can also trash and disassemble
barricades up in to the point where the
round ends we're not quite sure that
returns the material to you or not
but you have a limited amount of time to
do it all right so you made it through
the match what should you be doing back
in your staging area well depending on
how well you did you can use points to
toughen up and maintain your gear you
can put points into toughening your
character and individual skills like
heavy attacks or punching kicking and
tripping enemies and you can craft extra
material and send that to your
repository which is a storage box that
you can get to in the next round alright
that sugar you guys started on Metal
Gear survived salvage mission we'd love
to hear about your creative traps and
tactics so let us know in the comments
below don't forget to keep an eye on
gamespot.com as we cover more Metal Gear
survived up until launch
[Music]